let me read the DM really quick and
Jesse you can go and kind of go into it
so
um
goes hey Chris if you guys ever consider
doing other ladies night I'd love to
join I'm a conservative woman 28 years
old married to a high value man and some
of the women on here just really aren't
getting it and arguing pointlessly when
their man says no it's a no he leads and
knows what's best for the context of the
relationship within his leadership
thanks for your time have a nice day so
I would love to have you expand on that
a little bit and talk a little about
those views and your trust in your your
husband as a leader and sort of making
those decisions
yeah so um
um I've dated people before in the past
and I've noticed that once I you know
started this relationship and then got
married
um 95 of the arguments that we have had
in the past are because I'm not choosing
to submit I'm not choosing to let him
take it and trust him to do that and I
found that when I have allowed that and
now that we're in that stage um our
marriage is amazing it's going really
well
um he is the leader he goes to work I
work from home and take care of the
house and it's just it's a wonderful
marriage so yeah do you guys have kids
not yet hopefully soon what was the um
what was the Catalyst like why did you
have to shift like what like why did you
surrender why did you end up uh deciding
that you needed to submit to him and
follow his lead
um I think it was just like when I
realized I was doing it it was so much
easier I think when I was not doing it
it was just more of an experience like
when I noticed we were not in that sink
um I was having more issues we just
weren't getting along very well but I
noticed once I did it allowed him to
kind of step into that role fully and it
really just makes my life so much easier
so that I can kind of go into I guess
with my full feminine energy is kind of
more or less what I look at it as do you
fully trust him
to lead to be a man to be masculine like
yeah
do you think that and I guess this is a
question for all the women on the panel
like do you think that you could get to
a place where Jessica's at where you
could submit to a man and follow his
lead or does it have to be equal do you
guys have to be an equal partnership
like what's all your view on that
I'll start
um
I feel like I would never I don't know I
guess I don't like the word submit
because that makes it seem like
the power is being taken from me and
um
I don't know I'm also not religious so I
feel like you know trusting the man to
lead like
isn't really something that
I grew up hearing about and stuff so
that's just not a relationship that I
think I could be in but that doesn't
mean it doesn't work for you it
obviously does so what's what what power
is being stolen from you if I can just
get some clarity on that
relationship dynamic
Dynamic whether or not you see it or
feel it
um you know who makes the most money who
makes decisions if you have kids who is
the disciplinarian you know who's
who gets to make the choices who wears
the pants I guess in a sense and for me
to just totally lay on my back and
submit I'm not saying that's what you do
but the way I understand it
um I don't know that's just not
something I would be interested in but
personally this is not the reason why
there's only one steering wheel in a car
and there's a passenger seat on the
other side I think a relationship is a
lot more complex than the car okay a lot
more parts to that
okay
um Nicole you're kind of getting ready
to say something I want to hear it now
oh my
um
am I yeah that's the only way I would do
a relationship is if I fully trusted a
man to lead
um and to make decisions for our life as
a family
when I was younger I
did relationships a different way and
then when I switched the way I did
relationships they were much more
peaceful and fulfilling
and um
so that's actually when you say would I
be open to it that's really the only
dynamic
I would sign up for in marriage the
thing with that is that
I think that that Dynamic you know it is
a it is a Christian value right it comes
from Ephesians and I think there are a
lot of men who want women to submit
while they're not doing the first part
of what they're called to do
is to give their entire lives
sacrificially to a woman for her good
um so it's complicated but yeah if I
were to get married it would only be
within that dynamic
yeah
sorry
um I'd have to trust him 100 or I won't
marry him because of that yeah okay so
you got to be with a giant you got to
look up to him he's got to be somebody
that you could submit to and surrender
to yeah like if
it's like a life decision
say like
I trust his long-term thinking and
decision making and I'm going to give my
opinion and I might like butt heads back
and forth and that's healthy and good
but I I'd want to feel safe deferring to
him let me just um
hover on that for a sec before I go back
to Aubry so what would happen if you
would say like you were vehemently
opposed to a certain idea and he said
look that's just the way that it is it's
my way or the highway would you be okay
like would you be able to
take it back you know hop in the
passenger seat just be cool with that
yeah I mean a man that I would marry
would never say to me it's my way or the
highway I don't I think delivery so
you're vehemently opposed to his
position though you know at this point
oh if I'm vehemently um if it's not like
sinful if it doesn't go against our
shared values then
then I would I would go that way because
it has to go some way so
I'd go his way okay Aubry
um yeah I feel pretty similarly I'm not
gonna go into a relationship with the
person that I wouldn't trust to lead
um ultimately like women make a lot of
decisions based off their emotions and
are typically kind of more chaotic with
emotions than men are and so I think
it's important to be able to be able to
like step into
not like stepping to someone's brain but
kind of like allow them to take the lead
and make the decisions that would be
more difficult for you to make
um
Anna I think you said you're in
therapist or or you're can you do
therapy yes what do you do exactly
um as an LPC what's an LP a licensed uh
sorry I can't even a license
what is it something counselor I can't
think right now
practicing
I think so I was licensed not too long
ago so okay this is something that you
do every day or is this a part-time
thing are you schooling to get into it
or uh no I I do it remotely actually
from my house okay so like you do
couples counseling is that what it is
[Music]
hell no hell no that stuff oh no couples
is probably the worst individual is
is more my thing okay so
um
have you ever submitted to a guy before
like you ever found yourself in a
position where you know you just
saw this guy as like basically like the
he he's you know he's got it
together I can I can enter his frame I
can give myself to him trust him
everything or is that or or does that
expose you to Too Much discomfort
because I mean you said that uh would
you say earlier was uh something along
the lines of um you know giving up that
uh Freedom power power the power yeah
yeah
um
because I mean power is a strong word
right yeah I mean if the relationship is
mine that I'm in that's my life I would
like to be somewhat in control of my
life you know I don't want to submit to
a man like sure you can have a good idea
and we can talk about a decision and I
would love to be a part of that but if
you're gonna you know say oh this is
what we're doing like okay we can do
that but why I would like to be agreeing
to that and not just be like oh you're
the man so
let's go
I would agree with that like I when I
when I think about getting into a
relationship and trusting a man in that
way to lead in that way because I agree
I don't like the term submit because it
does kind of sound like almost like a
dog like submitting to its Master like I
don't I don't feel like I just when I
think about it that way
um I think on it more so
like in reference to the car there's
only one Driver's Seat but in the
passenger seat maybe you have the person
with the map that's telling you like
okay this is you know giving you
directions of like this is the quickest
way to get to this or this is my opinion
on whatever else but ultimately it's up
to that person of whether they're going
to steer the car that way or not yeah I
think Aubry hits on a really important
point but I want to go back to Anna
really quick
um it's like I don't know where what's
the fear right what do you you keep
saying giving up control giving up power
like what is this ultimate fear that you
have if you happen to like what
situation are you afraid of finding
yourself in if you give up this control
or give up this you know sovereignty
um I don't think it's fear but
I don't know I would just I would like
to be somewhat in control of my life
also you know in therapy I see a lot of
abuse in relationships and I'm not
saying that just because a man is in
control and has you know power whatever
that he's abusive but Financial abuse
huge I see that so much you know
emotions
so you understand
say that one more time you guys are both
talking if you can Define what Financial
abuse is just so we understand it so our
viewers understand it
um so Financial abuse is can be anybody
just making sure that you don't have
money that you don't have funds you
can't put gas in your car you can't go
um shutting down you know your bank
cards credit cards taking you off the
bank completely so you can't even apply
for a new card
um you know things like that
so shutting off your phone and making
sure that you don't have a phone anymore
okay okay yeah sorry go ahead
that's um
go ahead I was just gonna say like when
I I when I listen to you speak and I
don't doubt that these things happen in
marriages
when I'm thinking about submitting to a
husband I'm coming from a place of like
where I'm assuming he wants what's best
for me and what's good for me so
um because a good leader asks questions
he wants to give people like what they
want right like he's a he's like a
caring loving sacrificing leader like
this is like servant leadership almost
so I would expect my husband to like
want to please me and want to make me
happen happy and make me want to be open
and vulnerable he'll ask me like what do
you want to do what do you want to eat
like I think when a dynamic's healthy a
man ultimately wants to make a woman
happy and a woman wants to make him
happy
um of course there's always like
dysfunction but making models based off
like dysfunction I don't think is like
the best route I think there needs to be
like safety nets and things for
dysfunction but the norm I would think
is both parties being equal in dignity
with the man being the head having all
that responsibility on his shoulders to
make it work and to make the woman happy
and for her to you know be his 100
support so
well and I think even even getting into
that like from the beginning is it isn't
just giving I guess and like you said
like that power but it isn't just giving
that to a man right off the bat it's
going to the process of before you even
enter into a relationship with them like
they had they have to prove themselves
to you
um and work for it not just giving it to
anyone just because so it's after like
building that trust in them and knowing
that they do want the best for you and
not necessarily you know not making it
easy just not being easy for them to get
that necessarily not like playing games
but yeah you know that way it's
something that you are able to put trust
into that they do want what's best for
you kind of thing I think sorry but I
think this is more of a question for
maybe Nicole and Aubry at this point but
um what percentage of men that you've
come across that you've dated are
worthy of submitting to
are strong or virtuous our leaders are
competent are capable
um you know tick off the boxes where
you're willing to give yourself to them
and enter his frame and be a compliment
to his life and follow his lead
probably about the same amount of women
that are willing to do what you just
said I don't know
no they're not wrong not many not many
on either side like I I don't think it's
like a man or a woman thing I think it's
a both thing and it's just not a dynamic
that the majority you know are into is
this something that you've arrived at
recently
um Nicole or is it something that you've
sort of like always believed
about 10 or 11 years
okay
so so what changed over the 10 or 11
years like why did you shift from
um probably what Anna has you know as
far as a relief in that sense to where
you are today
um I think when I was younger I I came
to a point where I I felt that I I had
been sort of lied to like there was like
this sense of disillusionment and I felt
that I was like really cut off from a
big part of my Womanhood and my
maternity and I don't mean just
biological children
and so I just explored it myself and I
started reading and I ended up reverting
back to my Catholic faith and um
there was a man that I was with at the
time who was not a Believer but I just
sort of started acting as if with him
like letting him make decisions letting
him take the lead like and I was like oh
wow even with him this is so much better
we broke it off
um I didn't want to marry him because my
values had shifted and it didn't
and I knew that I wouldn't be able to
trust his leadership and that was like I
had decided that's what I wanted
so I was like okay I could get married
now and struggle or I could not get
married and then I may never get married
because of my age but I'd rather be
alone than in a backwards topsy-turvy
Dynamic so
yeah so it's been like a decade a little
over a decade
um let me ask you this question uh Anna
because the notion of submitting to a
man is like I'm looking at uh marriage
vows from different types of religion it
seems to be like it's infused into most
of them
um I pledge in honesty and with
sincerity to be with you for an obedient
and faithful wife right
um is that something that you would be
able to comfortably say at a wedding
ceremony to in front of your family in
front of the church in front of your
husband in front of everybody
like as you're saying it's sort of under
the towel or the the wrap or whatever
honestly if I ever get married like it's
probably not going to be in a church
um you know I already said I I didn't
grow up religious I still like if I
would love to believe in something I
really would but I just I I don't so
um could I say it yeah does it make me
uncomfortable no I'm glad other people
have faith makes you a better person
whatever great but it's just not
something that I've ever
like done I've tried I've tried to go to
church I had a boyfriend you know not
too long ago that
that's a long story but I went to church
for him and that just blew up in my face
so can you explain why like can you dive
down that for us everything that was
wrong with with me was because I didn't
know Jesus
and um any time that there was a
disagreement between us he would call
his mom and she would come over with a
Bible and read scripture thinking that
that would like somehow resolve the
fight I don't know that didn't turn you
on and didn't make him more attractive
absolutely not
um Jessica what's what advice do you
have like what is a woman's obligation
in a long-term relationship or a
marriage
oh gosh um
there's a lot
um
so when people say like oh I can't just
submit and just like do nothing I mean I
do a lot of stuff I mean you know I'm
making sure that the house is running
well and making sure that
um
cleaning my house making sure that my
husband has dinner on the table every
night making sure that things are
getting done organized within our home I
know that people might look at it like
oh you're just like a servant or
something but
you know we need those things to live
and Thrive so that he can go to work and
be the best person that he can be so
that he can come home and that we can
have time together make memories
together
um
yeah there's a lot of things that could
go into it but
I think that hits back to aubry's point
of the passenger with the map right I
think that there's this misconception
that guys out there just want robots
made of plastic and silicone just to sit
there and shut up and just to be you
know seen and not heard and all the guys
that I know in our community and the
guys that I know that are an accessible
successful ltrs are better looking to be
in successful ltrs are looking for
a woman to compliment their life and you
know I think Jessica you hit on a really
important point there are things that
your husband is free to do because he
doesn't have to worry about dinner being
ready or the house being clean or you
know you are able to make his life
easier and free of time so he can work
more hours he can be more in a relaxed
mood so you guys can enjoy time and
spending together
um you know and I think that's what most
guys are looking for they're looking at
a complimentary and a interdependent
relationship you know I I talk about
this all the time where I think we've
completely overshot you know 50 years
ago 60 years ago like no one's disputing
that women couldn't get credit cards or
sometimes they couldn't open bank
accounts or sometimes they weren't even
allowed to work and they were completely
dependent on their husband
um and we've gone from a completely
dependent dependence model to a
Independence model I mean independent in
itself means by yourself it means
separate from one another
and we are no longer we completely
skipped over interdependence where each
person brings something valuable and
complementary to the other to
Independence where you have two people
that are fighting for this control and
you're these men out here that are
looking for you know relationships if
that's what they're doing or they're
looking for women to spend time with the
last thing they want to do is argue and
bicker and have to negotiate over every
single little decision that might affect
the both of you I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full-length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out